alors seulement scolaire c'est quoi
aujourd'hui je vais m'adresser à vous
d'abord benoît clair enquête au
quotidien le monsieur harcèlement en
bourgogne franche comté avec votre
exemple à dijon c'est la souffrance
d'enfants qu'ils subissent de la part
d'autres camarades de façon répétée de
la violence physique verbale soit de
visu soit sur les réseaux sociaux on
parlait de réseaux sociaux ont parlé d'
images vous propose justement de voir ce
qu'est le harcèlement scolaire en images
on a préparé un petit reportage qui
revient pour essayer de vous donner
quelques solutions regarde c'est bizarre
théo n'aime plus aller à l'école alors
qu'ils adorent et ça c'est peut-être du
harcèlement scolaire tissé en france le
harcèlement scolaire touche un enfant
sur 10 de 14 % des enfants en primaire
se déclare harceler contre 12% au
collège et seulement 2 à 3% au lycée les
garçons sont le plus souvent agressés
physiquement et les filles sont plus
sujettes aux cyber harcèlement en
particulier au collège on parle
d'harcèlement lorsque la victime se
retrouve isolé et lorsque les agressions
qu'elle soit physique verbale ou même
d'ordre sexuel sont répétées mais
harcèlement scolaire ne veut pas dire
forcément dans l'enceinte de l'école
dans plus de la moitié des cas à 3 5% il
s'agit de cyber violence c'est à dire
sur les réseaux sociaux
hélas pas très surprenant les filles
sont beaucoup plus exposés une cyber
violences de nature sexistes ou sexuelle
mais se rendre compte qu'un enfant est
victime de harcèlement n'a rien
d'évident tout brusques changements de
comportement ou de repli sur soi peuvent
être un signe si vous avez découvert que
votre enfant est harcelé par les ans à
la direction de l'établissement scolaire
ils sont aujourd'hui formés pour mettre
en place une réponse appropriée ou bien
appeler le 30 20 même en cas de doute
c'est gratuit et des professionnels vous
aideront allo allo allo nicolas
c'est une réaction sur ce que vous me
voir oui en fait ce qui me frappe
énormément manquée coûte des jeunes
depuis très longtemps assez que les
symptômes souvent nous n'ont pas été
rassemblés en fait et on regarde
beaucoup le symptôme scolaire c'est à
dire que comme ce spécialiste
d'apprendre à apprendre les paroles on
m'appelle pour travailler avec leurs
enfants sur mieux apprendre et au bout
de quelques heures de coaching
ce qui va apparaître effectivement c'est
qu'ils y vont oser nommé ce qui se joue
et qu'après il va falloir négocier
qu'ils acceptent de le dire aux parents
donc je pense que je dois être en amour
effectivement de la paix là à ce numéro
mais c'est pas c'est pas évident et ça
me frappe énormément effectivement et je
suis très touché par cette détresse
le plus compliqué aujourd'hui finalement
c'est d'en parler c'est pas très évident
à quel moment vous vous intervenez
benoît clair alors au moins on
intervient au moment où quelqu'un nous
appelle sur le train de vin par exemple
donc on est systématiquement prévenus
que c'est une situation dans le dans
l'académie et donc du coup entre en
contact avec la famille en priorité et
ensuite on prend contact avec
l'établissement scolaire pour voir
comment faire pour faire cesser cette
situation
voilà et même si je tiens à le dire
parce que notre petit reportage c'est
mes marques et que 55% se font sur la
cyber violence semir harcèlement même si
ça se fait en dehors de l'école si ça a
un impact à l'intérieur de l'école on
peut quand même agir c'est à dire qu' on
ne peut pas il ya des parents qui nous
disent mais comme c'est pas dans l'école
vous pouvez rien faire si on peut faire
quelque chose parce que ça a un impact
dans l'école donc là on parle de qualité
d'élève donc comme cette année lève on
peut les aider
que faites vous concrètement pour faire
cesser ce harcèlement et peut-être
j'espère en tout cas apporter des
solutions et faire en sorte que ça
fonctionne à la fine pointe à l'ample là
je parlais de l'académie de dijon parce
que je trouve c'est un exemple encore
une fois ce jour là je vous dis chaque
je voulais le département on pouvait pas
recevoir les sur les huit monsieur
harcèlement scolaire de bambou en france
et si vous êtes vraiment sur le terrain
moi je voulais pas un politique voulait
quelqu'un qui me disent qu'est ce qui se
passe quand je décroche mon téléphone
que j'appelle le 30 20 que je tombe sur
quelqu'un qui me répond et qui me dit
oui on va s'occuper de vous re ce cube
de moi comment et qu'est ce qu'on fait
alors dans chaque département on a des
référents départementaux harcèlement qui
sont là pour prendre contact avec la
famille les rencontrer on vous rappelez
vous appelle vous me rappelez oui
exactement ça c'est déjà la première
chose que vous faites tourner le fait et
on appelle en priorité la famille
elle s'en prend le temps de discuter
avec eux voir où en est la situation
voir exactement comment ils ressenti de
la part de la famille comment l'enfant
est aussi et ensuite on prend contact
avec établissements scolaires dans un
second temps parce que il n'ya pas de ya
pas qu réponse type
chaque situation est différente en
fonction de l'enfant en fonction de la
famille en fonction de l'établissement
scolaire on doit pas répondre de la même
façon ça va dépendre de ça va dépendre
des besoins de l'enfant je regrette
unique
chaque cas est unique oui chaque cas est
unique on a des situations où l'enfant
préfère partir de l'établissement
scolaire donc on l'aide à partir de
l'établissement scolaire mais il ya
d'autres situations l'enfant ne veut pas
partir parce qu'il sent une deuxième
fois coupable
donc du coup il estime qu'il doit rester
donc voilà la réponse est vraiment
adapté à la situation
on va faire une autre réponse à une
question posée sur notre plateforme
attractive 7 0 805 383 383 bonjour quel
est votre question s'il vous plaît
bonjour nariman 49 ans j'aimerais poser
une question concernant le harcèlement
scolaire
pourquoi les enseignants du moins
certains enseignants ne sont pas formés
à l'empathie et à la bienveillance pour
mieux accueillir la parole de l'enfant
ou de l'adolescent
merci merci à vous pour votre question
surtout norman je vous ai senti un petit
peu tiqué benoît rapport à cette
interrogation recueillir la parole de
l'enfant quand on est ancien je sais qu
on demande beaucoup aux enseignants a
peut-être même un peu trop mais est ce
que les enseignants sont formés alors
ils sont en train de se faire former ne
l'est pas par rapport à notre projet
académique un des piliers c'est le
bien-être à l'école et la bienveillance
donc des formations sont mis en place
voilà dans cette dans ce but là savoir
recueillir la parole de l'élève le
bien-être à l'école et au delà de ça en
parallèle de sa aussi former les
enseignants à avoir les signes
précurseurs du harcèlement est vigilant
dans la classe justement sur ces femmes
aussi je me tourne vers vous cette fois
ci nicole vous me disiez intervenir vous
finalement un petit peu plus peut-être
en amont que que benoît qui lui va
tenter d'apporter les solutions
concrètes sur le terrain sur le milieu
scolaire
quels sont les signes qui doivent nous
alerter parce que ça c'est vraiment une
question qui revient très très souvent
on parle souvent d'isolement chez
l'enfant l'enfant qu'il veut plus aller
à l'école
son matériel et de détériorer on lui
pique son blouson et cetera
vous quotidien c'est vraiment quelque
chose que vous avez l'habitude de
traiter oui en fait très souvent nous
les parents le signe qui est le plus
flagrant c'est la baisse des notes à
l'école
et puis aussi une certaine longueur pour
aller à l'école le matin mais en général
on nous dit toujours il a des problèmes
à l'école
il est dispersé sur le dernier bulletin
il ya de mauvaises appréciations et en
général en fait on tire ce fils parce
que mon coin vous savez on est très fort
mais sur le non verbal et donc on se
rend bien compte que dans la prise de
parole il ya quelque chose qui est tu es
donc l'objectif c'est comment est ce que
on va dérouler la possibilité de
rassembler des informations un double du
temps ils sont pas invités les
anniversaires
il ya quelque chose effectivement enfin
qui est liée à leur problème d'identité
ça peut aussi des maux de ventre ça peut
être plein de chose de particulier je
sais que la diététicienne aussi
rencontre beaucoup d'enfants des jeunes
et parfois vous même dans votre cabinet
vous pouvez être confronté à ça et
découvrir que finalement l'enfant
souffre de harcèlement scolaire
très souvent notamment sur des prises de
poids est ce qu'il y ait une
compensation alimentaire qui se fait
parce que l'enfant ait mal et pas bien
ça dans sa peau et son seul doudou pour
réconforter ses longs j'ai effectivement
il ya des prises de poids dans ce qui
rajoute encore en plus leurs séances
scolaires sur le physique sur deûle en
fait si vite à la maison retard de
règles chez les filles jean pagé minutes
tout à fait voilà alors c'est pas parce
que il se passe tout ça aussi non plus
quand on est harcelé à l'école inconso
bien d'accord bon je vous propose
d'écouter le témoignage maintenant d'une
maman au 0 805 383 383 vous avez la
parole véronique je voudrais vous
raconter l'histoire de mon fils harcelé
pendant plusieurs années qui est venue
au secours d'un camarade en classe de
sixième ce camarade malade depuis des
mois était en fait victime de
harcèlement au sein du collège qui
fréquentaient tous les deux donc monfils
a fait circuler une lettre au sein de sa
classe ou professeurs et élèves on
voyait des encouragements pour que ce
petit garçon revienne en cours y est
revenu monfils s'est engagé à le
protéger à la compagnie aux toilettes au
self dans la cour de récréation
ce petit garçon est revenu
comme quoi ne restez pas passif ne
restez pas passif quand vous sentez que
quelqu'un est en danger intervenez
dénoncer et d eleur si véronique pour
votre témoignage et puis pour le courage
de votre fils ou si c'est vrai que c'est
important le témoignage
on dit il faut pas dénoncer malgré tout
à dénoncer ça peut être aidé dans ce
cas-là libérer la parole c'est pas
évident dans un collège dans un lycée
belin voulu vous le savez bien
on passe parfois pour des balances aux
yeux de ses camarades ce qu'on essaye de
faire dans les formations canton à berne
devant l'élève c'est à dire que quand on
les forme sur le sur la prise en charge
bio mars helmand on travaille beaucoup
sur les témoins en insistant sur le fait
que si vous êtes témoin de situations de
harcèlement allez en parler un adulte ce
n'est pas balancer comme le dit le
moment mais c'est aider la personne qui
est en souffrance
donc on travaille sur l'empathie montre
un peu les conséquences que peut avoir
le harcèlement pour faire prendre
conscience aux élèves que oui l'élève
souffre donc il faut l'aider et c'est
intéressant ce qu'elle a dit parce que
en train de développer en train de
développer sur l'académie enfin ça
serait un peu partout même dans la
france des ambassadeurs collégiens c'est
à dire qu'on va former des collégiens
qui vont être un peu des personnes
vigilante dans les établissements
scolaires et qui vont être menées auprès
des adultes
quand ici conti lieux sont témoins d'une
situation un peu problématique
en tout cas il ya un numéro de téléphone
qu'on va vous remettre un sur sur la
fiche on le voit bien c'est le 30 20
services et appels gratuits alors après
il ya le hashtag non au sahara
harcèlement et le facebook etc
il ya le site internet mais au delà de
toute la communication aujourd'hui on
prend vraiment ça très très au sérieux
connerie tout à fait il 30-20 il ouvert
à tous ainsi là où il ouvert aux parents
ils ouverts aux enfants ils ouverts aux
grands parents c'est vraiment voilà vous
êtes pris en charge par un psychologue
moment pour faire le point avec me et
après en fonction des académies on
reprend contact avec les familles mais
il faut surtout pas hésité à l'appeler
c'est vraiment le moyen de commencer à
en parler alors il ya le harceler ou
larcelet aussi le harceleur oui tout à
fait après l'annoncé travaille dessus
parce que les personnes qui harcèle son
cd personnes qui sont en souffrance
donc quand on a une situation de
harcèlement on travaille sur les deux en
même temps parce qu'on doit travailler
aussi sur la personne qui harcèle pour
pas qu'elle recommence et voit aussi les
problèmes qu'il ya derrière pour lui
vous voyez des petits rats je sais qu'on
n'aime pas ce mot là des petits caïds ou
de petites d'ailleurs un qui harcèlent
parfois sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment parce que c'est très à la mode
alors clairement dans ma clientèle non
l'entrée elle se fait toujours par la
victime et par cette solitude profonde
mais par contre ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'il m'arrive d'avoir des adultes
en coaching qui viennent pour apprendre
quelque chose de nouveau
un nouveau logiciel ou autre et vous
très vite on va voir qu'on touche les
zones où bout d'un moment la personne va
dire la voilà je viens de remettre en
souvenir on appuie sur le bouton et
s'allumant à ce qu'on appelle marqueur
somatiques chez nous avec les travaux
d'anthony damasio et la personne là tout
de suite se dit mais c'est une émotion
qui est là qui est vraiment
effectivement en marqué pour toujours
dans mon histoire de lui donc c'est
vraiment important je trouve ça
extraordinaire de voir que l'éducation
nationale prend ça en charge et je suis
vraiment heureuse parce que c'est une
douleur mais d'une profondeur qu'on ne
peut même pas imaginer au travers de vos
expériences à tous les deux même je peux
le dire tous les trois puisque vous dans
votre cabinet vous recevez aussi des
jeunes
est-ce que c'est plutôt les garçons ou
les filles aujourd'hui qui sont entre
guillemets harcelé à l'école mais aussi
le petit reportage le disent eh bien on
va être plus plutôt être sûr de la
violence physique pour les gars s'en est
plutôt sur les réseaux sociaux pour les
filles mais les réseaux sociaux n'ont
pas n'ont pas augmenté non une situation
de harcèlement est les contribuables
n'ont pas beaucoup de cyber harcèlement
mais c'est en ça n'a pas fait augmenter
le nombre total de situations de
harcèlement c1 c'est un facteur en plus
il ya un profil type du harceler nicole
benoît or aurélia j'oserais dire qu'est
ce que ça me paraît vraiment important
c'est que la grosse différence avec
annoncé qu'avant le harceleur c'était le
caïd
maintenant le harceleur ça peut être
l'âge les services grâce aux cyber
harcèlement
weekes cache derrière les réseaux
sociaux et autres profils effectivement
de lars eller
c'est d'autant plus compliqué à déceler
ah oui s'agit pas de faire une enquête
de police un forcément mais trouve
voilà c'est pas votre rôle vous n'êtes
pas là pour ça il ya des sanctions
malgré tout benoît ont pu sanctionner
oui tout à fait oui oui c'est ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure même par
rapport aux cyber harcèlement étant
donné que ça a un impact sur la qualité
d'élèves dans l'établissement scolaire
le chef d'établissement peut engager une
procédure disciplinaire
de fait il ya quand même des des
solutions le sport par exemple ça peut
aider noir seulement je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez
ça peut aider pour lutter
on les gamins victimes de harcèlement
toutes les activités effectivement qui
vont redonner la confiance en soi je
voudrais juste raconter une toute petite
chose m'a tellement troublé un petit
gamin qui était effectivement harceler
il est arrivé avec un cadeau à la
dernière heure en fait il m'a offert une
boule à neige vous savez où il y avait à
l'intérieur un petit ours et par dessus
une cloche et mais je te remercie
d'avoir appris de m'avoir appris à
mettre la cloche par dessus pour me
protéger et laisser la neige tombée et
me dire tu es quelqu'un de bien j'ai
trouvé ça je le partage puisque cette
solitude et cette impression d'arriver à
se protéger site allemand important
voilà l'enjeu